how do we count the flowers
so this first choice they go one
two
three
and then they don't count this one and
then they skip it and they go four
five six and then they skip this one
again and then they say seven eight
that's not how you count flowers you
would say this is four this is five six
seven eight
nine ten so this first choice is not
right now the second one looks better
one two three four
they didn't skip this one five six seven
eight
nine ten that one looks good so i'll
click right over here
and check my answer
how do we count the mice
let's see one
two this isn't the third mouse this is
the second mouse this is crazy this
isn't right all right this one over here
one two three four five six seven this
is right
up here they skipped the number two they
should be the second mouse not the third
mouse
all right
let's keep going
type the missing numbers it says count
the ladybugs
type the missing numbers in the boxes
alright this is ladybug number one
two then let me type three
then let me type four
it's a lot of fun
type count the flowers type the missing
numbers in the boxes this is flower
number one flower number two i'm just
going to type that right in there check
it let me do one more
how do we count the flowers so we saw
one like this a few questions ago one
two three
four five six seven eight nine ten
that one looks good
this one just like the last time they
skipped actually they skipped the same
ones this wouldn't be the right way to
do it so we select this one right here
and then we're done